volodymyr excelente que llegó al poder
en abril de 2019 sin ninguna experiencia
política ni militar
este hombre de 44 años sólo era conocido
por su carrera como actor
el presidente ucraniano se encuentra
ahora en la primera línea de la crisis
más grave en europa desde la guerra fría
nuestros chicos y chicas todos
defensores de ucrania no permitieron que
el enemigo pusiera en práctica el plan
operativo de invasión el primer día los
ucranianos demostraron verdadero
heroísmo el enemigo fue detenido en la
mayoría de las direcciones por un súper
negro ahora se enfrenta a una formidable
fuerza rusa ya que el presidente
vladimir putin señala que está
intentando desmilitarizar y desmasificar
ucrania los expertos afirman que el
objetivo de putin es derrocar el régimen
de kiev el líder ucraniano asegura que
su destino está en juego y ya
permanezco en la capital mi familia
también está en ucrania mis hijos están
en ucrania mi familia nuestra y dora son
ciudadanos ucranianos no tengo derecho a
decir dónde están exactamente
según la información que tenemos el
enemigo me ha marcado como objetivo
número uno y a mi familia como objetivo
número 2
excelencia ha pedido ayuda a la otan
pero hasta ahora sólo ha recibido equipo
militar y ayuda financiera